la france a donc emboîté le pas à
l'allemagne aux pays bas le gouvernement
a annoncé que les volailles élevées en
plein air devront être confiné jusqu'au
1er décembre dans 21 départements
une décision destinée à prévenir tous
risques de grippe aviaire dans ces zones
emprunté par les oiseaux migrateurs
nicolas chateauneuf francis tanger des
milliers de volailles ces battantes en
plein air une dernière fois dans cette
exploitation d'alsace jean michel
schaeffer élèves 5000 chapon à l'air
libre à partir de demain il a
l'obligation de les maintenir enfermés
dans le bâtiment principal le matin en
fait on ouvre notre app et on laisse
sortir les animaux et donc à partir de
demain en fait on va les laisser donc
l'intérieur des bâtiments
le confinement des volailles est
désormais obligatoire dans 21
départements censés être les plus
exposés au contact avec des oiseaux
migrateurs sur les 916 millions de
volailles d'élevage que compte la france
11 millions sont concernés quant à
celles qu'on ne peut enfermer
elles auront un traitement spécial ce
moment là les vaches qui ne peut être
confiné parce qu'il n'ya pas de bâtiment
et sous une surveillance particulière
que cette surveillance renforcée en bref
ces élevages recevront la visite
régulière de vétérinaire au total 3000
400 éleveurs en plein air sont visés par
le confinement
les éleveurs qui n'entendent pas assumer
seul les coûts supplémentaires
si la société demande à ce qu'il ya plus
de sécurité sanitaire donc de sécurité
alimentaire nous contredira jean paul
jammes
nous sommes pour mais nous disons très
clairement ce sont les éleveurs les
producteurs qui doivent payer et pour
casser toujours contre la grippe aviaire
les rassemblements d'oiseaux vivants
dans les marchés foires et expositions
sont désormais interdites et ce dans
toute la france interdit aussi la
pratique à la chasse du canard vivant
placé comme appât toutes ces mesures
seront maintenus jusqu'au 1er décembre
date de la fin de la migration vers le
sud de certains oiseaux potentiellement
affectés